a desperately sad situation and also a
live investigation
both the public the police and her
family will want this investigation to
hold those responsible to account
if people do have information then i
would appeal for any witnesses or people
who may have been in the area at the
time or people who may have dash cam
footage to contact the police on 101
quoting incident 419 of the 28th of july
2022
similarly people can report via crime
stoppers if they have any information
that they believe would assist this
investigation
any information no matter how small
could be key in ensuring justice for
this child
similarly whilst we have more officers
out in the local area to reassure the
community if you have any issues or
concerns please do approach your local
neighbourhood policing teams
the area has currently been cordoned off
and will remain cordoned off whilst our
scenes of crime officers gather all of
the necessary evidence
this incident has shocked our community
in boston and i'd like to reassure the
community that we're doing absolutely
everything we can to progress the
investigation and to support the family
thank you
there we go that is the latest from
boston in lincolnshire where we
understand two people have been arrested
in connection with the death of a
nine-year-old girl in a suspected
stabbing incident in boston we will have
more on that story throughout the
morning here on sky news
but now we're going to have a look at
this morning's business pages the
financial times leads with centraka's
call yesterday for the uk government to
do more to help households hammered by
the energy crisis it notes that the
owner of british gas which resumed
dividend payments after three years will
be paying more than 600 million pounds
to the government as a result of the
windfall tax on north sea oil producers
the ft also reports on its front page
that developers in west london face a
potential ban on new housing projects
under until 2035 because the electricity
grid has run out of capacity to support
new homes and this is because of the
number of data centers